a deadly Hospital explosion in Gaza and
an American president trying to prevent
the conflict from spreading the Israeli
Hamas War has drawn worldwide attention
and expert warns Russia could try to use
it to its advantage in a different
conflict the Russian regime right now is
just fundamentally
anti-western and and really wants to
weaken the West in every way it can and
uh a broader War in in the Middle East
is is one way to do that the kremlings
campaign in Ukraine continues but faces
Fierce resistance the country has a
close Ally in the Middle East Iran which
has a partner the militia Hezbollah in
Lebanon it like Hamas is dedicated to
destroying Israel the likelihood of heah
entering I think very much depends on um
the possibility of a grand invasion in
Gaza Middle East expert Marissa corma
says say so far Hezbollah has been
relatively restrained and that it's too
early to know whether Russia could get
involved but papova says the Kremlin is
likely hoping any expansion of the
conflict would draw us focus into the
Middle East and away from Ukraine
support for Ukraine is really strong in
Congress so is the funding Todd belt
says but the US can't approve more money
for either country without a house
Speaker the vote for which is currently
gridlocked belt says money already
approved will last at least a little
while but the US should prepare for more
Hamas and Israel are in the news whereas
the war in Ukraine is more uh
longstanding uh then we'll probably see
a tension go back and forth neither
conflict showing any sign so far of
ending soon Nathaniel Dove Global News